buona sera si sono un fisico nessuno è
perfetto
purtroppo l'italiano è un po ambiguo
perché in genere quando si dice un bel
fisico si pensa a una bella attrice non
bella modella oppure un bel attore
modello quando si dice brutto fisico
pensare sempre a me allora di cosa siano
fatte shakespeare la tempesta dice che
siamo fatti della stessa materia di cui
sono stati sono fatti i sogni in realtà
i sogni le stelle sono molto molto
vicini vedremo questa cosa perché ci
siamo mi sono iscritto a fisica abbiamo
fatto al primo anno tanti e tanti anni
fa una specie di sondaggio e alla
maggior parte dei ragazzi e nel
femminucce ce n'erano poche erano
essenzialmente si erano iscritti a
fisica banalmente perché un po di
misoginia interesse alla conoscenza
eccetera in realtà non si batteva un
chiodo e quindi tutto sommato seguendo
quello che un premio nobel
richard feynman che insegnano ministra
di stanford ha detto la fisica e come il
sesso di sicuro ci porta qualche pratica
diciamo risultato però non è esattamente
questo per cui lo facciamo e io ho
scelto la fisica
allora stasera cercheremo sempre se
riesco a non cadere dal palcoscenico di
capire un attimo di che cosa è fatta la
materia in qualche maniera da dove
veniamo
cosa tiene tutti assieme sono le domande
che ci siamo sempre posti dall'inizio in
cui l'uomo ha iniziato ovviamente a
pensare la sotto piccolo piccolo ci sono
scritte due frasi che sono molto
importanti e che dovete tenere a mente a
ricordare la scienza non fornisce
risposte ma riduce solo le nostre
incertezze se volete una risposta alla
dovete cercare in altri edifici
allora due concetti base prima di
iniziare poi faremo un giochino la
fisica si occupa essenzialmente due cose
la massa e le interazioni tra le masse
ma sono le cose gli oggetti a qualunque
livello di dimensione e l'interazione
sono quelle che noi chiamiamo le forze
tra gli oggetti
sembra strano ma la fisica praticamente
si riduce a questo tipo di cose
e sapete benissimo che è un oggetto per
noi e massivo secondo applichiamo una
forza accelera poco l'elefante oppure
poco massiva una piccola massa se come
un'ape a una mosca eccetera io applico
la stessa forza è questo schizza via
questa è la differenza poi tralasciamo
il fatto che la massa e il peso sono due
cose diverse
allora facciamo un attimo un esercizio
perché io ho bisogno che poi impariate
queste cose 2 x 2 fa 4 2 x 2 x 2 fa 8 e
la sequenza e 2 4 8 16 32 64 128 256 e
512 1024 2048 4096 e così via
ieri sua memoria quindi per capire
quello che mi interessa invece le
potenze del 10 10 100 1000 e ce la
facciamo su giochino vogliamo un
giornale qualunque lo dividiamo in due
studi in due lo dividiamo in due lo
dividiamo in due lo dividiamo in due lo
dividiamo ancora in due adesso
incomincia avere qualche problema non
tanto perché le dimensioni sono piccola
perché la costola della piegatura mi
crea delle difficoltà
supponiamo che io la taglio alla fine
cosa voglio fare voglio cercare di
capire se io continuo e arrivo per
esempio fino a 2 alla 64 che dimensioni
avrei allora facciamo un discorso molto
banale prendo un libro libro libro
dell'ignoranza proprio indicatissimo più
o meno è un centimetro
ci sono circa 200 facciate quindi 100
fogli diciamo che è un decimo di
millimetro e lo spessore di un foglio
del
abbiamo perso ma tanto non ci serve
perfetto
adesso qual è il problema è quando
sarebbe grande
un numero una serie di risme di carta o
un libro ipotetico il cui numero di
fogli equivale a due per esempio alla 64
beh non vi faccio perdere tempo
vi faccio vedere il risultato non è
necessario che loro già te perché è
piccolo ma e 1.900 miliardi di
chilometri che si degli sperimentali voi
andate a casa compra del giornale
incominciata a piegarlo e poi mi dite se
effettivamente è così
questo che cosa significa che tenendo
conto della distanza terra luna o terra
sole praticamente piegare un giornale 64
volte arriva essere circa 5 milioni di
volte la distanza tra la terra e la luna
e 12 mila volte quella del terrasole poi
mi direte che sono pazzo in realtà il
problema è che voi dovete pensare che io
non sto sommando 2 ma sto raddoppiando
quindi raddoppio raddoppio raddoppio di
volte che il raddoppio diventa sempre
più grande adesso se col 2 semplice
perché piego un giornale
immaginiamo se lo volessi fare col 10 10
alla 64 non c'è bisogno anche in questo
caso che facciate i conti guardate
queste due questi due triangoli questo è
il numero di cifre di due alla 64 e
questo è il numero di cifre che servono
per 10 alla 64ma bene perché vi dico
questi numeri perché noi abitiamo in un
paese in un paesino che l'italia piccolo
piccolo rispetto a un alla terra 12.000
chilometri di diametro di dieci alla 7
metri che uno dei tanti pianeti numero
dei pianeti purtroppo vari a seconda del
comitato scientifico attualmente sono 8
per capirci dove c'è il sole
questo sistema solare sta nella galassia
l'amico e cioè la
la galassia dove viviamo noi la via
lattea e scordatevi che non stiamo al
centro dell'universo stiamo in un
angolino alla periferia delle barriere
della via lattea una galassia e 100
milioni di milioni di volte più grande
della terra una galassia contiene un
milione di milioni di stelle ma non è
una sapete quante galassie ci sono
dell'universo abbiamo contato qualche
stimato qualcosa come 100 mila milioni
di galassie per un totale di un numero
incredibilmente ampio 10.000 mila di
miliardi di stelle tutte fatte negli
stessi elementi di che cosa siamo fatti
noi siamo fatti essenzialmente una
zolletta di zucchero capirete ai cavalli
di zollette di zucchero piacciono molto
sono fatti praticamente un insieme di
atomi l'atomo lo sapete è un oggetto non
indivisibile con un nucleo centrale
degli elettroni che diciamo gli stanno
attorno
il nucleo centrale è fatto di due
particelle protoni e neutroni i quali a
loro volta sono fatti ognuno di tre
oggetti che noi chiamiamo cuork va bene
il neutrone è fatto da tre cuork uno si
chiama ap gli altri due da un giu
e il protone e 2 up e andando su un nome
di fantasia non è importante sapere
perché va bene ora con questi due cuork
che stanno nel protone neutrone è
l'elettrone che gira attorno abbiamo
fatto tutta la materia che conosciamo i
neutrini sono una cosa in più che serve
nelle reazioni nucleari
abbiamo scoperto altri cuochi quote sono
sei
abbiamo scoperto due fratelli più
pesanti dell'elettrone ma questi non si
trovano normalmente in natura
decadono molto velocemente in altre
particelle quindi in pratica l'unica
cosa che ci interessa noi è questa ok
siamo praticamente vuoti se voi vedete
questo è il rapporto tra le dimensioni
del nucleo è del dell'atomo intero cioè
il nucleo più gli elettroni lontani è un
fattore 10 mila
come dire che se il nucleo è grande come
una nocciola
cm e mezzo voi che siete l'elettrone
state nell'ultimo posto della gradinata
tutto il resto è completamente vuoto e
si tiene assieme ricordate perché la
materia ha bisogno di interagire quindi
ci sono delle forze che fanno sì che
l'atomo si tenga e si aggreghi agli
altri atomi ma noi siamo praticamente
vuoti io potrei passare tranquillamente
al dentro e attraversare voi se non
fosse per il fatto che tra la nocciola e
chi sta sugli spalti c'è un'interazione
perfetto
quali sono le forze che conosciamo noi
forza gravitazionale la conoscete
benissimo e quella che agissero la
materia avete imparato appena cadente la
prima volta elettromagnetica e quella
che vi permette di parlare col cellulare
e si sono altri due forze che non
conoscete che sono a nucleare forte che
impedisce al nucleo di di slegarsi e la
cosiddetta nucleare debole che attiene
al dica di menti per esempio radioattivi
queste due forze voi non le conoscete
non le conosciamo noi va bene
tutte queste forze mentre queste due
agiscono l'infinito queste due hanno un
raggio di azione molto ma molto piccolo
allora quali sono i problemi aperti che
abbiamo oggi
il primo è questo la velocità delle
stelle nelle galassie lontane è maggiore
di quella che uno penserebbe
come dire che se io faccio girare questo
oggetto supponendo che questo
questa è una galassia che gira girerà
una certa velocità in funzione di quanto
io gli stia dando l'impulso di quanto
sia rigira la corda suppone che a un
certo punto questo oggetto inizia a
girare come un matto vuol dire che oltre
alla forza e la mia mano c'è qualche
altra cosa che io non vedo e questo è
responsabile del fatto che anziché avere
questo andamento
io ho man mano che mi allontano al
centro la galassia un andamento in cui
la velocità di rotazione e maggiore
questo non me lo so spiegare
seconda cosa effetto di lenta e proprio
una lente tipo la lente ottica no quella
che usate per in grande
einstein 1917 relatività generale
la luce quando passa vicino a un oggetto
molto ma molto massivo derya anziché
andare dritta
abbiamo anche in questo caso un evidenza
sperimentale il fatto che vediamo degli
oggetti che dovrebbero stare in un posto
di vediamo come se stessero altrove
quindi capiamo che lì c'è qualcosa che
non vediamo queste due cose ci portano
al fatto che ci deve essere della massa
dell'universo che noi non riusciamo a
misurare con dico vedere intende
possiamo misurare con gli strumenti
secondo effetto la velocità di crescita
dell'universo sta accelerando
questo è oggi come vedete c'è una curva
che dice che sta accelerando ora
qualunque scoppio tipo big bang che non
immaginate
diciamo che aumenta aumenta poi rallenta
in teoria uno potrebbe pensare che si
ferma e magari o ritorni indietro come
si ferma invece pensato a un qualcosa
che man mano che passa il tempo accelera
questo che significa significa che
l'uomo è fatto di acqua e proteine
essenzialmente la terra è fatta
essenzialmente di ferro noi conosciamo
solo meno del 5 per cento del nostro
universo
il resto 95 per cento sono cose che noi
non conosciamo
cioè non siamo riusciti a capire ancora
che cos'è questo perciò vi dico la
scienza riduce alle nostre incertezze ma
purtroppo non è che ci dà cognizione di
tutto
l'altra cosa e perché siamo fatti di
materia poiché esistono le particelle ma
esistono anche le antiparticelle cioè
l'antimateria l'avete sentita parlare
sapete che se un oggetto di materia
incontra un oggetto di antimateria fa
pur crea energia e sparisce ma noi
esistiamo
quindi vuol dire che noi siamo fatti
solo di una di queste due cose va bene
quindi questo è un altro problema che si
chiama asimmetria materia antimateria
noi siamo molto legati alle particelle
siamo fatti di particelle l'avete visto
idrogeno azoto carbonio ossigeno sony
ricostituenti principali gli elettroni i
nuclei eccetera
siamo fatti una persona di circa 70 kg
di massa ci sono 7 per dice la 27 a
tommy cioè praticamente 7 miliardi di
miliardi di miliardi di atomi queste
persone qui a voi non sembra ma sono
esattamente fatte le stesse cose se vi
sembrano diversi o se provate qualche
attrazione per l'una e non per l'altra
non chiedetelo a noi fisici perché non
ve lo sappiamo dire produciamo
particelle per che ingeriamo potassio
ingeriamo carbonio in particolare questi
sono gli isotopi radioattivi
per esempio il potassio nelle banane per
dire mangiano banane c'erano tasse
quindi se dormite una notte abbracciata
e al vostro partner sappiate che vi
beccate le radiazioni sue e nello stesso
tempo lui ovviamente si becca le vostre
siamo attraversati da particelle
continuamente raggi cosmici che arrivano
dall universo ma anche neutrini frutto
delle reazioni solari e neutrini dal
centro della terra in ogni centimetro
quadro per esempio e mezzo polpastrello
mio in un secondo passano circa 65
miliardi di neutrini provenienti
dall'universo ma non attraversano solo
il mio dito
poiché non interagiscono maicon nulla
attraverso la terra e continuano
dall'altra parte
noi viviamo bene tranquillamente lo
stesso allora da dove veniamo a noi
abbiamo bisogno di studiare cosa sta
succedendo
all'inizio dell'universo l'universo è
nato con diciamo grande big bang grande
scoppio ha avuto un'espansione
rapidissima va bene dopodiché
noi cerchiamo di andare a studiare con
delle macchine gigantesche cosa è
avvenuto un decimo di miliardesimo di
secondo
allora anima fa la caccia alle
particelle non con il falcone di
federico ii ovviamente abbiamo bisogno
di un acceleratore di un sistema che ci
permetta di vedere cosa succede quando
io faccio portare un protone e un altro
protone adesso ve lo dirò di un sistema
di colpi compiuti molto elevato e
ovviamente di tanti ma tanti ricercatori
questo è il sito del cern di ginevra
l'acceleratore di cui parlerò adesso
brevemente è un oggetto che ha una
circonferenza di 27 chilometri sta 100
metri sotto terra questo è il lago di
ginevra geni versa acqua questa il reo
porto di cene con train ferney voltaire
me
e tutti i paesi e questi questa è la
francia e questo è il massiccio del
giura perfetto l'acceleratore un oggetto
del genere sempre a dritto ma in realtà
ovviamente 27 chilometri di
circonferenza sta curando i due
esperimenti di cui quello a cui
partecipo io è questo qua più piccolino
pesano 12mila 500 tonnellate atlas il
mio e cms e atlas 7.000 per confronto la
torre eiffel e 8.000 non tutti hanno
immaginate l'avete vista non tutti di
voi hanno avuto la fortuna di andare a
parigi a vedere la torre eiffel e circa
500 tonnellate e quest'altro oggetto che
qualcuno di voi ha avuto la fortuna per
15 20 secondi di vedere transitare in
questa città
l'apparato sperimentale è una gigantesca
macchina fotografica questo è un omino
va bene molto molto grande e serve a
andare a misurare tutti i prodotti che
vengono fuori quando noi facciamo
riscontrare un protone con un altro
protone molto vicini creano un nucleo di
energia da questo punto escono tante
particelle noi andiamo là a studiare che
cosa succede bambino rompe il giocattolo
per capire come è fatto dentro noi
facciamo esattamente la stessa cosa con
le particelle elementari
solo che ne pigliamo tante tante tante
va bene e vi facciamo scontrare per
cercare degli eventi rari un evento raro
tipico è quello in cui abbiamo prodotto
avete saputo che un paio d'anni fa
abbiamo scoperto il cosiddetto bosone di
higgs di cui non ho il tempo di parlarvi
il bosone di higgs viene identificato
con delle particelle secondarie abbiamo
creato oppure una pizza al mio collega
per luigi paolucci è il precedente
l'infn nando ferroni hanno inventato a
napoli a un pizzaiolo questa veste è
andata pizza bosone di higgs ovviamente
è una molto buona
che cos'è il nostro apparato è una
macchina fotografica con 100 milioni di
canali banale
le macchine di oggi quelle che costano
40 megapixel quindi non è tanto tanto
difficile avere un oggetto del genere il
problema che le nostre macchine non
fanno 40.000 40 milioni di foto al
secondo con 25 soggetti tutti assieme e
elettronica e computer immediatamente da
tutte queste foto ne tirano fuori
qualche centinaia dove diciamo il
protone
come diciamo noi sorride il tutto viene
mandata una rete di computer che stanno
distribuiti del mondo abbiamo qualcosa
come 350 400mila cpu tutte quante
collegate cioè io mando un programma in
esecuzione per fare dei conti non so in
quale parte del mondo va non mi
interessa c'è un'organizzazione che
decide la macchina vuota dove mandarlo e
poi milano i risultati 170 centri di
calcolo in 42 paesi
la nostra comunità è molto elevata siamo
2200 circa 3500 nel giro degli ultimi 15
anni hanno costruito questa gigantesca
macchina 190 e passa istituzioni è
l'unico posto al mondo quello della
fisica scusatemi ma lo dico con orgoglio
nel quale riusciamo a far lavorare
assieme persone che vengono da paesi
diversi che tipicamente si fanno anche
la guerra quindi pakistani indiani
americani e iraniani palestinesi
israeliani e udite udite riusciamo a far
lavorare anche italiani con altri
italiani che la cosa più complicata
detto questo qua si vede un pacchetto di
protoni che arriva dentro vedete queste
tracce noi le andiamo a individuare e
sono un evento che può essere raro
ovviamente ne abbiamo tanti che non sono
rari e quelli poi li rigettiamo quindi
di fatto quello che ci interessa questo
è un evento vero ricostruito è un
oggetto del genere questi 4 sono dei
buoni identificano chiaramente la
presenza di un bosone di higgs che è
decaduto qua dentro
ok sarebbe tutto semplice se non per il
fatto che ogni 25 miliardesimi di
secondo noi vediamo questo
frattempo 25 miliardesimi di secondo
dopo arrivano altri protoni che creano
questa cosa quindi capite cosa c'è
dietro per tirare fuori questa cosa qui
da questo marasma di particelle di
spaghetti va bene abbiamo fatto un
lavoro dopo di che un paio d'anni fa
qualcosa di più nobel ma insomma nel
abbiamo i due responsabili lei la
conoscete di sicura ma perché era la
fabiola gianotti ca del suo direttore
generale del cern lui e incandela
un'italoamericana erano i due
responsabili di due esperimenti e grazie
a noi
peter hicks e françois riflettano avuto
il premio nobel come vedete nella
spiegazione c'è scritto grazie
ovviamente alle due collaborazioni di
5mila persone che nel giro di 25 anni di
progettazione 15 anni di costruzione
sono arrivati a questo risultato
allora a che serve tutta sta roba e mi
avvio con poche trasparenze a concludere
il minis cancelliere dello scacchiere
permesso della finanza inglese visitò un
noto fisico britannico e gli domandò
guardando delle esperienze
sull'elettricità sulle lettrici sono ma
queste cose che servono giustamente lui
rispose non saprei ma un giorno ci
metterete una tassa sopra allora io non
ho la più pallida idea di che cosa ci
potremmo fare con queste scoperte però
sappiate che qualunque cosa noi abbiamo
scoperto nella fisica nella chimica
della biologia della biochimica eccetera
poi dopo anno
qualche risultato il web abbiamo
inventato dal cern di ginevra
adesso lo usa di tutti tutte isis
dispositivi di diagnostica medica che
sono la tac la pet la nmr su tutti
basati su principi della fisica scoperte
della fisica quindi è ovvio
faccio un esempio le onde radio si
chiamano onde radio perché quando
l'hanno scoperta di una delle onde
elettromagnetiche nessuno la chiamava
radio perché non esisteva la radio la
radio è stata inventata dopo quando si è
scoperto che con le onde
elettromagnetiche si poteva trasferire
dei segnali che poi con un altoparlante
diventava dell'auto quindi voglio dire
qualunque cosa viene fatta anche se non
sappiamo immediatamente nella ricerca di
base a che cosa servono
un esempio voi potete migliorare la
candela come volete
cercando uno stoppino migliore la
qualità della cera la dimensione e la
forma più larga più bassa ma la candela
sempre candelari risulterà dove è stata
la parola innovazione fondamentale dove
è stata l'innovazione nel passare tra la
parte di bruciare l'ossigeno alla parte
dell'elettromagnetismo in cui questo
oggetto lampadina funziona c'è un
passaggio enorme tra qui e qui
non solo ma adesso non si useranno più
queste se non fosse stato per la
meccanica quantistica non si sarebbero
inventati i semiconduttori e
semiconduttori in cimentavano i led e se
non si inventavano i led non avremmo
oggi quest'altra lampadina che fa sempre
luce ma l'innovazione nel passare dall
elettromagnetismo alla meccanica
quantistica un oggetto completamente
diverso poi miglioreremo questo
troveremo un giorno qualche altra cosa
uno dice una punto costa tutta sta roba
beh in 15 anni abbiamo speso tra la
macchina acceleratrice gli apparati o
sei miliardi e mezzo dico madonna quanti
sono 6 miliardi e mezzo perfetto 13
miliardi e un mese di guerra 14 miliardi
è stato la l'intera spesa per olimpiadi
di londra l'ultima ovviamente
noi dati ma guardate un po tra fatturato
e utili di queste tre cosette aziende
private
qual è il confronto quindi è chiaro che
anche quando vi dicono a non possiamo
spendere tanti soldi in realtà non è
vero i soldi spesi l'italia contribuisce
con il 12 per cento a quella cifra
l'amica la spesa solo l'italia ha speso
una comunità incredibile ok che c'entra
col beautiful in ugly è questa qui è la
parte brutta della fisica non me la
spiego questa è l'equazione che regola
tutto quello che io vi ho detto fino
adesso cioè tutta la interazione e le
masse delle particelle elementari è un
po complessa perchè è brutta per noi
perché noi ne vorremmo una piccola
funzionante come diremmo noi elegante
bella va bene e quindi cerchiamo di
operare per minimizzare questo tipo di
complessità
io non sono sicuro che esiste il brutto
e quindi le ultime due foto che vi metto
a vi cito john keats nell'indie mio che
dice che letto da sotto ovviamente et
incompiuti su joi forever il solare
lines in crisis it will never was in the
knot ines come dire è praticamente c'è
una cosa bella sarà comunque bella una
gioia per sempre e ovviamente il fascino
aumenta e non si sperde non si perderà
mai nel nulla
ultima cosa e poi me ne vado e vi lascio
tranquilli e 1988 mostra dell'istituto
nazionale di fisica nucleare c'era un
giovane fisico chiamato nicola cavallo
che spiegava a una troupe di cinesi che
era venuta a portata dall ambasciata
domani a napoli per fare visite di vario
tipo ci hanno portato qui per un quarto
d'ora ho spiegato in inglese stata una
delle mie prime performance di
divulgazione e questo medicinesi a
differenza degli italiani sono molto
cordiali poi ti ringraziano tutte
genuflettono eccetera quindi ti danno
tutta questa soddisfazione già mentre
parli che tutto sommato apprezzano anche
lo sforzo che io poi all'inizio diciamo
l'inglese lo sapevo ma insomma non
proprio per parlare in pubblico
e stata una esperienza molto bella la
sera sono andato a cena con alcuni
colleghi e c'era anche il rappresentante
dell'ambasciata che mia mi ha detto che
erano tutti molto contenti e cioè c'era
poi dopo un attimo mi ha guardato ha
detto senta ma io le devo dire una cosa
dice sì
che cos'è loro non sanno l'inglese
parlano solo cinesi
mi auguro che voi siate italiani e che
siete riusciti a capire qualcosa
grazie